- HOWDY, LONDON, I COME FROM THE OL’ U.S. OF A.
- London loves mediocre Minshew!
- Hey, y'all, I fixed it!
- GARDNER MINSHEW HAS SOLVED BREXIT!
- Everyone loves my backup more than me.
I wish someone could relate…
- WELL, WELL—
- How did I handle being hurt while you stole my city’s heart?
By HUNTING.
And prayer, of course.
You just gotta relax—
- I’M TELLING YOU, WENTZ PROVES IT EVERYDAY. WE SHOULD HAVE STUCK WITH
CHIP KELLY AND TAKEN MARIOT—
- Not listen to local talk radio, and—
- Woah.
- Guys, you gotta catch that...
- [Nelson Agholor:] Sorry!
- YOU’RE NOT GOING TO REPLACE ME, Brendon Allen.
Is it Brenden? It’s Brandon.
- I replaced my backup no problem, see?
AHHHHHHHHH!
- Look, it’s a tense time for everyone around the league.
- The haters have @#$%!*& won...
- HOW DARE YOU ASK ME THAT ABOUT KRAFT!
- No, no, no. I asked if he had a message for the team.
- Not a question but the way you hand the ball to McCaffrey is amazing.
- Yeah, I wouldn’t rush back, Nick.
- Take that!
- Why do they catch it for him?
- [Alshon Jeffery:] IT’S SIMPLER WHEN HE DOES IT.
- I GOT MY BIG NICK ENERGY BACK!
QB1 in DUUUVALLL!
- Yeah, we’re all going to start again!
- I'm Eli, and lately I've had some time to learn about the internet.
You can subscribe below, whatever that means.
Here let me type in Eli Manni⁠—
Oh, no....